[Música]
de una familia tradicional y por
tradicional me refiero de los singles
excepto que no vivimos en el campo
tuve una infancia muy feliz leía mucho y
eso me abrió la puerta a un montón de
mundos imaginarios y charlas conmigo
misma
aunque esa capacidad de imaginar y esa
forma de ver el mundo no era
precisamente lo que más le gustaba de mí
a mis compañeros de la escuela
me encantaba practicar deportes de
equipo y me gustaba hacer reír a mis
compañeras mi sobrenombre en basket era
la payasito imagínense más o menos
al ir creciendo mis compañeros eligieron
que ya no era graciosa y empezaron a
comentar sobre otras cualidades mi
cuerpo mi estatura mi peso hasta mis
preguntas a los profesores
eso ahora tiene un nombre
antes hace un poco más de 10 años
solamente eran cosas de chicos
para encajar en este estándar en el que
la mayoría de mis compañías se encajaba
desarrollé un trastorno alimentario
no sé si ya escucharon hablar de la
bulimia
con cada gramo que perdí una parte de mi
personalidad burbujeante se iba apagando
me convertí en ese estereotipo
cuando terminé el secundario decidí
cambiar el foco y mi carrera de
licenciada en kinesiología tomó la
primera plana de mi vida
y estudiando el cuerpo desde su
funcionalidad y no su estética me
entendí me comprendía como un
instrumento y no como un ornamento
con esta idea comenzó a traspasar el
límite de mi estereotipo del estereotipo
que yo me había armado
durante cuatro años fue el rango
fui capitana del equipo y forme parte de
la selección entrerriana de rugby
y desbloquee en ese espacio el nivel
como en los jueguitos del líder acá y mi
personalidad burbujeante volvió a
aparecer se basó efervescente que tanto
tiempo había tapado volvió
pasó el tiempo y
decidí empezar a cambiar un poco el
rumbo
empecé a preguntarme mucho por qué no
tuve la suerte de casarme con un cerebro
muy particular muy similar al mío y
decidimos que aunque íbamos a estar
casados no vamos a hacer una sola carne
una sola persona y vamos a reforzar
nuestras individualidades en todas esas
preguntas que surgieron en este después
de este por qué no
empecé por ejemplo a preguntarme por qué
no practicar un deporte artístico
siempre venía de los deportes en equipo
y bueno ahora croacia se hago croacia
sentí la colgada solita de hacia arriba
me pregunte también por qué no trabajar
de manera independiente
ahora manejo mis horarios elijo y
disfruto realmente el momento en que
trabajo
otra pregunta por qué no postular a un
concurso de belleza
detrás de mis prejuicios y de los
estereotipos que había observado durante
tanto tiempo estaba esta profesión
que hoy disfruto y por la que hoy estoy
acá soy modelo
porque no era la pregunta
y por ahí cambiarlo un poco y preguntar
porque sí
porque en este momento en que como
sociedad estamos tratando de traspasar
todos los límites de buscar otros
paradigmas que funcionen
nos damos cuenta que nos ha picado un
poco a muchos y por ahí es lo que se ve
ahora el bichito de la inquietud es como
que lo vivimos siempre ya no nos
funciona
por ahí con todo este respaldo que tenía
de todas las las cosas que viví lo que
aprendí durante mis 24 años
fue que tome esta decisión este por qué
no
tuve que empezar desde algún lado
armarme a pararme después de lo que
había aprendido y empecé por aceptar
básicamente lo que tenía y dije bueno
esto es lo que hay
bastante bien
qué puedo hacer con todo esto que tengo
que lo que puedo transmitir que lo que
puedo cambiar con esto y bueno tome
acción sin pedir muchas opiniones sin
buscar la aprobación de muchas personas
porque la opinión más importante que era
la mía ya la tenía firmada ahí en
cuadrado
me topé de nuevo con con los
estereotipos y todo este trabajo que yo
venía haciendo cobró sentido cuando las
personas empezaron a opinar sobre fotos
como la está
que no es más que mi cuerpo al natural
despojado de todo retoque y de todas
fue duro fue
una experiencia súper motivante poder
tomar todas esas tres herramientas y
llevarlas a lo positivo darme cuenta de
que esta imagen solamente muestra mi
cuerpo no muestra mi historia no muestra
mis aciertos no muestra los momentos
oscuros que superen como los
estereotipos esta imagen es incompleta
los estereotipos solamente encierran una
parte de todo lo que podemos hacer
nos coartan nos alejan de quizás todo lo
que podemos lograr si traspasamos ese
límite
soy maría cecilia estévez tengo 24 años
soy un kinesiólogo ex back bien modelo
acróbata aérea me gusta el rey me gusta
la música clásica me gusta la moda me
gusta andar en pijama
quiero hacerles esta pregunta
que me la hice y me la hago todos los
días qué tal si todo lo que soñamos ser
todo lo que queremos ser todo lo que
queremos para nuestras ciudades todo lo
que queremos para nuestra vida está
justo atrás de esa pared enorme
construida por estereotipos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]